- [Evan] Lead us to victory!
Lead us to victory, new colony, on Mars!
Lily also wants Tony to
put his hand on her head.
- Yeah, I want to feel small for once.
- [Evan] Lily's a troublemaker!
- It happens to me often!
(energetic upbeat music)
- Hello, Believe Nation!
We're heading to airport right now!
We're going to go to LA!
- What's up, Believe Nation? (laughs)
We just got back from
Disney, three days ago.
And we decided, hey,
let's go on another trip!
We are off to LA.
I'm bringing Nina
and three of my people
from Toronto Dance Salsa.
We are going to the Tony
Robbins event there.
- Unleash the power within!
- Unleash the power within.
Nina's got a lot of power.
So, neither of us have been
to a Tony Robbins event.
- No.
And I'm excited.
- I'm scared.
- Nina's scared.
Scary is good.
It's good to be scared.
We're going to see what
we can do with the video.
You're not allowed to bring any videos in.
So, we definitely won't be filming inside.
But, document some of the trip.
And meet some of the
people we're going with.
And we'll have some fun!
We're going to start by
meeting up with Mike and Lily,
who are right here!
We're takin' Lily with us!
- Hey!
- [Evan] We're takin' Lily!
We're leavin' Mike, but
we're takin' Lily with us!
- Put so much stuff in a small backpack?
- [Evan] Nina's a small person!
- Your backpack is smaller!
- [Evan] I'm a small person, too?
Here we go!
Time to travel!
(energetic upbeat music)
- Exciting stuff!
- This is Lily!
What do ya do, Lily?
- Well, no, I do lots of things!
- Lots of things?
- Yeah!
I'm the extreme learner!
- So, Lily does a lot of
different classes at TDS.
Salsa, Zumba...
- Soon to be heels!
- Heels?
Oh, the heels!
Yeah, heels!
- Personal workshops!
- And she's doing our first
Your One Word workshop,
coming up in April!
Although, this might be--
- Oh, yeah!
- It might've already
passed, I don't know.
Anyway, she's doing the
first Your One Word workshop.
I'm excited.
Nina's way ahead of us.
We got to catch up.
(light upbeat music)
You're cold!
It's okay, we're going to LA, don't worry.
We're going to LA.
Nina and I got through.
Lily got the X on her random picture.
So, she's still in line.
She's gettin' the detailed questions.
And as we were comin' through security,
the security guard said,
"Remember, take control of your life."
I'm like, yeah, I like that!
(Nina and Evan chuckling)
I feel like we should always
get inspirational messages
from airport security.
Good job, US airport security!
We found her!
- Was so nervous!
- [Evan] Lily's a troublemaker!
- It happens to me often!
- [Evan] It's 'cause you,
you took too long to answer
the questions on the screen.
Lily's like reading each question.
Like, do I have firearms?
Let me think about if I have firearms.
- Well, I need to!
I need to make sure--
- You just click no to all,
and go!
We're hungry, so we're going
to get some Booster Juice.
Nina's tryin' to catch some Pokemon.
Nina!
How's the Pokemon?
We know you're lookin' at Pokemon!
We know it!
- [Lily] Pokemon's still goin' on?
- [Evan] Especially with Nina!
Anywhere she goes somewhere
new, she's looking for Pokemon!
What's at the airport, Nina?
- Nothing!
- [Evan] Nothing, so sad.
What are we doing?
What's happening here?
Who are we saying hi to?
- Snapchat friends!
- [Evan] Oh, Snapchat!
I missed it!
I missed my moment!
- It's ten seconds.
- [Evan] You got one opportunity!
- Ten seconds to tell
your story, and that's it.
- [Evan] Very sad, very sad.
(light energetic music)
How are we doin', Nina?
- (exclaims) Mine's yummier!
- [Evan] Lily's pants are falling down!
Uh oh!
(Evan laughing)
Okay, it's not that kind of channel, Lily!
It's not that kind of channel!
- (chuckles) What?
- [Evan] Family friendly content here.
Okay, we're here a little bit early.
Actually, a lot of bit early.
That's okay.
We're going to film some
inspressos for you guys, yeah!
Hey, look who showed up!
- Oh, whoa, what, hey!
- [Evan] It's Aleks and Edwin!
They're joining us on our trip as well!
- Yeah, thank you for inviting us!
Appreciate it!
It was a smooth entrance so far!
I didn't have any weird pat-downs.
So, they didn't pick me
for that special room area.
You know, that weird random check.
I've had a lot of those in my life!
- [Evan] Actually, Lily
got random checked!
- She got checked?
- [Evan] (laughing) Yeah!
- Wow!
(Aleks and Evan laughing)
What's he got in here, you know?
What she's hiding in that
hair, Lily, razor blades?
What's going on in there?
- [Evan] I think she
took too long to answer--
- [Lily] No, I need to ask,
I need to know what I'm answering!
- [Evan] Yeah, she took too
long to answer the question
of are you bringing
firearms into the country,
and she's like thinkin' about it.
So, the response time
was too slow. (laughs)
- How do you define firearms? (laughs)
Okay, so we had our receipts printed.
I got my receipt.
I come down.
I'm waiting for his.
His gets printed.
- I had an X on mine.
I asked her is everything okay.
She said, "No, I mean, yes!"
(group laughing)
- [Evan] You join Lily!
- But, you know what, solidarity!
She looks at me, she's like,
"You want to join him?"
I'm like, yes, I am going to
join him on the left side!
- [Evan] Oh, that's good.
Nina and I left Lily. (laughs)
- Well, it's hard to do,
if we're not together.
- [Evan] We told Lily
we're going to pretend
like we don't know you!
- Wow!
(Evan and Aleks laughing)
- So, everybody's hungry.
Aleks and Edwin haven't eaten yet.
So, the men are going to go hunt for food.
We're going to get some Wahlburgers.
Why do you want to go to Wahlburgers?
- Well, actually, it's funny!
About a year ago, or two years ago,
I was watching a Wahlberg movie,
and then, I watched his documentary.
And he was talking about the burger place
and how he started it for his family.
- Have you seen the reality show?
- No, I haven't actually.
- It's called Wahlburgers.
I mean--
- Yeah, yeah,
about his family, yeah, yeah, yeah!
I haven't seen the show.
Anyways, so...
- You want to test it out.
- Yeah, I do!
I do!
- They have one at the
Toronto Airport, guys!
Best city in the world!
(Aleks chuckling)
- It's the best city in the world!
Toronto Airport, best city in the world!
- Toronto is the best city in the world.
And city, home of Believe.
(energetic music)
- [Evan] What's happening, Aleks?
- I'm smelling the poutine.
I can't eat it.
That's what's happening.
- [Evan] Aleks wants to eat.
- I do.
- [Evan] Thank you kindly!
Thank you!
Nina said she wanted a bacon burger
and they had two options.
One had jalapeno peppers on it
and I didn't feel that she'd enjoy that.
So, I just got her the other
one that was a bacon burger
and only realized afterwards
that it's a half a pound of beef.
- Which is a apparently a lot!
- And we also ordered other dinner.
And she also wanted side fries.
So, we'll see how Nina does.
It was Aleks' idea.
(Aleks laughing)
- Okay.
- We can't throw Aleks
under the bus like that.
Although, we did talk
about, on the way in,
maybe one night,
we should wake you up at
like three in the morning
with a camera.
- Oh, by the way, I actually
move my hands when I sleep.
So, my hand, or my foot,
randomly goes up when I sleep!
So, just a heads up!
If you see one of my hands,
in the middle of the night,
just like being raised above
my head, don't freak out.
- I think we definitely--
- Like, legitimately!
And if you can actually
get that on camera,
that's pretty awesome!
I mean, is that a good lens?
Can I catch that at nighttime?
- Oh, this has infrared, yeah, yeah, yeah!
- Oh yeah?
- This is nice at night!
- Okay.
- Okay, we got to try to find
Aleks infrared--
- Just make sure you tell me,
'cause I don't want to go
all buff and go to sleep.
Tell me the night you're going to--
- There's blankets, dude.
- Yeah, but you move around, whatever.
Especially, because my
arms move around, right?
I don't sleepwalk!
- There are some things
that you can't un-see!
(Aleks laughing)
Alright, let's go find the girls!
Alright, Nina!
So, we got you the junior burger.
- Why junior?
- [Evan] So, enjoy.
- You underestimate my...
- [Evan] Your hunger?
- [Lily] Her pint size.
- [Evan] Okay.
So, I got fries.
- [Aleks] This is your water, Lil.
- [Lily] Thank you, sir!
- Is that the junior?
- [Evan] Open it.
- That's Our burger.
- [Evan] No, that's mine.
You got the other one.
- Why?
- [Evan] Okay?
Don't eat mine.
Mine's yummy.
- [Aleks] She just wants
to see if she wants--
- [Evan] Yeah!
That's the Our burger!
That's the best one!
Okay, there's your--
- Why are you giving me the not best one?
- [Evan] The junior burger!
You wanted bacon!
- I don't want the junior!
You can add bacon to the burger!
- [Evan] Nina's opening her junior burger.
It's actually half a pound of meat, Nina.
It's the opposite of the junior burger.
It's the biggest burger they have.
See, I did not underestimate
your appetite! (laughs)
How is it, yummy?
Huh, yummy?
Okay, good.
Time to eat.
We're going to show you
how Lily eats her ketchup.
- [Lily] You're going to find
out I have a lot of weird--
- [Evan] She opens the ketchup pack
and then dips the ketchup in.
- [Lily] No mess!
Guys, you got to use
your creativity, guys.
- [Aleks] What's the
alternative way to eating it,
that you think it will make a mess?
- Like, spilling it all over the place.
And then, different food
touches different foods.
- [Evan] Aleks is very intrigued.
How's the poutine?
- [Lily] You should try it out!
- It's not bad!
The gravy's not so great, though.
I'll be honest.
- [Nina] Can I try one?
- [Evan] She's going to say, oh yeah,
I hear what you're saying.
- It's different poutine taste.
- [Aleks] Yeah.
- Tastes a little burnt.
- [Aleks] Exactly.
- We're all going to the
Tony Robbins conference
for two reasons.
One is, hopefully, to
improve ourselves, to learn.
The reason why I picked these guys, what,
was they were the first ones, at TDS,
to embrace their one word, and find it.
So, Nina is...
- What?
- What's your one word?
- Oh, kids.
- Lily is...
- Extraordinary.
- Edwin is...
- Together.
- [Evan] And Aleks is...
- Belong.
- So, I wanted to reward them,
and take them to go see Tony.
And, hopefully, he can
share some insights,
to help all of us become
better versions of ourselves.
Also, we're teachers.
And I wanted to learn from Tony.
And we teach three hours at
night, three different classes.
Tony's on stage for, like,
eight, ten, 12 hours at a time.
And I was hopin' that, maybe,
we could learn something from him,
that we could bring to
our classes as well,
to be better instructors.
So, we'll see.
I'm excited to learn from him.
So, we're going to go around the room,
and find out one thing that
everybody is hoping to learn
from this session in LA.
- I don't know.
I've been thinking, lately,
there are things that I always want to do,
and I will just think about it.
I don't do it.
So, I was thinking I
should just go for it.
I shouldn't think too long.
Take action, right away.
Take actions.
- [Evan] Boom!
- There's actually several
things I want to work on.
But, the most important thing is that
I feel like my outside
does not reflect my inside.
Like, inside, I feel like a beast!
And the outside, I'm
more like a goat, maybe.
(Evan imitating goat noise)
Right?
Yeah, like a small goat!
So, I really, really
feel like I just need to
manifest what's inside of me.
There's something holding me back.
- [Evan] Beast mode!
- I don't know what it is.
I need to find out.
- [Evan] I like it.
- [Edwin] I think I want
to be able to tap into
the reason why I chose my one word.
And be able to have it
reflect it off my every day,
a lot like Lily's tapping the beast,
and wanting to be able to tap into that,
and share it, 24/7.
- [Evan] I love it, yes!
- [Aleks] So, what's the one
thing that I want to work on?
I want to work on being a
better leader, for everyone,
and a better example.
I think I'm holding myself back.
I'm holding myself back, because
a lot of limiting beliefs,
procrastination and a bunch of things.
And it frustrates me,
because I can be playing at
a higher level, and I'm not.
So, I'm hoping to find
some answers about myself.
- [Evan] Yeah, boom!
For me, I'm most excited
for the experience.
I surround myself with this
kind of content, daily.
And there is nobody else that I would
really want to go and meet.
There's nobody I want to
meet, like one-on-one,
and pick their brain.
But, I'm excited to go
and just be a part of the experience.
And I'm not necessarily looking
for any one thing, I'm open.
I'm open to being surprised.
And I want to feel it.
I want to see how Tony does it.
And I want to see what comes from him.
- [Lily] Nice.
- That's what I got.
And I want my hair rubbed.
(Nina laughing)
Mission accomplished.
Lily also wants Tony to
put his hand on her head.
- Yeah, I want to feel small for once.
I mean, I want to unleash the beast,
but at the same time,
physically, I want to feel small.
It's weird!
(Aleks and Edwin conversing)
I have a lot of limiting beliefs!
(Evan laughing)
- It's time to board!
(light energetic music)
I got the aisle seat.
Nina's in the middle.
Edwin's got the window.
He's excited.
On the other side...
The other side, we got Aleks and Lily...
- For five hours, six hours.
- It's going to feel like ten.
- [Evan] Yeah, like ten!
(Evan laughing)
- Wow!
- I'm glad I'm on this
side of the airplane.
I'm glad I'm on this side of the airplane.
We met a fan of the channel,
Michael, on the plane.
- If you're looking to buy
a property in Toronto...
- Check out Michael Duggal.
He's coming to the Tony
Robbins event, too!
And what's your favorite
video on the channel?
- All of them are great!
You start with a really
great introduction.
It keeps me ready, engaged.
I've watched the Bill
Gates, the Warren Buffett,
the Will Smith.
The Steve Jobs.
I think you do a great job
of selecting what interview,
because I can just subscribe,
and watch day after day,
whether it's while I'm eating
breakfast, or eating dinner,
or I just need something
positive at night.
So, I thank you for the videos.
- Cool, man!
- I saw you, Evan,
and I was talking, is this
is really him? (laughs)
- Michael Duggal, ladies and gentlemen.
Go check him out.
(light electronic music)
We made it!
We are in LA!
We had this fun game,
where we had to connect
Scarlett Johansson to Brad Pitt.
And we finally figured it out.
I'm not great with movie trivia.
Kind of get very competitive
with these things.
So, we figured it out, as a team effort.
Lily really helped us.
- [Lily] Yes, I did!
- I believe.
- [Lily] We came up with a funner game!
- What was a funner game?
Oh, Six TVs of Entrepreneurs!
That was a pretty good game.
- [Lily] That was easier.
- [Evan] Welcome to LA, everyone!
We're going to find an Uber,
and head to our Airbnb,
and rock this thing!
Alright, our Uber is here! (exclaims)
- I will be shotgunning.
Are you okay with that, Evan?
- [Evan] Go for it, Aleks!
- Alright!
- [Evan] Fearless leader!
Lead us to victory!
Lead us to victory, new colony, on Mars!
Aleks Saiyan, everyone!
Alright, it's just past
three in the morning, for us.
Midnight here, in LA.
We are going to get some
sleep, settle into our place.
I don't think I'll be able to film
and bring the camera tomorrow.
We can't bring recording devices in.
So, maybe we'll do an intro
and take some pictures
for you guys.
Looking forward to gettin' some shut-eye,
and gettin' up early,
to go register for Tony Robbins,
and hopefully have some
coffee with my sister,
who's also comin' for the event!
I'm excited!
We'll see you soon!